[Music]
this
is star talk cosmic queries edition
which
is becoming quite the fan favorite and
you know i don't do this alone
i need help help me check
well yes i'm here but you don't need
help but i'm i'm always here
okay you give me uh spiritual help
exactly
there you go right because i'm certainly
not helping to answer the questions
that's for sure
so this one is is a sort of a fan
appreciation episode
yeah where um i think it's primarily
patreon questions
all patreons these are our supporters i
think you know you're not just a patron
i think that's why the the word is
different
you know when you're a patron you just
hand money and out of charity but
patreon there's actually sort of a uh
what do you call it a contract between
the money you give
and what happens next yeah and so and
there's a scale
uh with higher and higher rewards for it
so yeah
uh so that's so we're trying to just
encourage that
because it allows us to experiment those
those funds
right do things that are not yet tested
in the marketplace
and that but but we think it will work
and then we get to test it and then it
works then we go on to something else
so yeah they're giving us the
opportunity to fail
with without consequence that's
basically i haven't thought about it
that way
that's what they're doing it's like
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to fail
and we don't have to worry about it we
can you know but you know
that's a good thing right yeah those who
are the only people who no longer make
mistakes are those who are no longer on
the frontier of inquiry
oh did you just think that up that's
really good
oh no you're going to write it down what
is right in this
yeah mistakes are evidence that you're
exploring they're not evidence of your
failure so i have to agree with you
yeah cool man yeah we have to change our
attitude by the way if you make the same
mistake twice
no excuse that's a different story
that's a difference it's a whole new
ball game
that's a different that's a different
show right
so what so you collected all the
questions so what do you have for me
yeah so but first we're going to try
something different what's up
speaking of patreon we have some patrons
that
do a yeoman's job of supporting us
okay i buy that i mean they they drop
some coin
drop some coin okay drop some coin and
so you know we like to reward them
um especially okay um
uh joel jericho um
is is going to lead us off with a
video question this is like like in
jeopardy you have the video daily double
yeah
i forgot about that just a little
moment of silence for alex trebek oh god
yeah yeah host of jeopardy for what 36
years
what an incredible career he had yeah
and i've been
i was never a contestant but i was
multiple times on the board
either delivering clues or my name was
like
the clue so i feel genetically connected
in my own little way well you know and
of course there's a big
buzz uh in the twitterverse
intern webs that you should be the host
oh yeah but i
i'm flattered i'm flattered but i got i
got
i got a day job i got a job yeah i got a
day
by the way i think i could do a good job
but it's not
it's not my life's goal it's not my
here's my impression of you
as the host of jeopardy
and so they give the answer and then the
person
uh chimes in
and then you go i'm sorry uh the
question we have there isn't quite right
because i'm pretty sure that that
question isn't exactly right yeah
they messed that one up right
technically maybe but no
yeah so anyway all right so let's
let's uh kick things off by the way just
just another quick thing
there people uh when i went to college
there was someone who had like a very
high iq
who lived in my dorm and his iq was so
high
that it couldn't be measured by normal
tests so they had to create a special
test for him
and then he was a consultant to people
who write iq tests for how to test
people at very
this is while he was in college he was a
consultant to test writers to test
people at very very
high iq and so it's weird it's its own
thing
it's its own universe this this iq thing
that's insane yeah so what he was
wondering
was whether iq correlated with your
performance in school
only to a certain point right then a
higher iq would get you lower grades
and so i ask well what's what's going on
there he said oh because beyond a
certain iq
you are smarter than anyone asking the
question
and so you will see answers that they do
not yet see
and then you'll be marked wrong makes
sense
so i thought that was an interesting uh
an interesting fact
no that i'm not claiming a very high iq
but this happened to me a couple of
times in school when i was in
kindergarten and i made a crayon drawing
of the night of the universe it was the
sky
okay exactly it's right earth and then
the sky and i used my black crayon and
totally wore it out
put in some stars in it and the teacher
said uh no
no the the night sky is dark blue and
i'm thinking
no this is like why would it not it's
like no
but but i'm like six or five or
something and so
later on the teacher went home did
research it came back he said no you're
right
the the nighttime sky is black right and
so that's what happened there
and and and so when she said it's dark
blue was your answer
so do you have eyes
no i'm five okay it's like a full grown
up teacher
and it happened again there was a there
was a question on the uh
physics regents i think it was where new
york state would take a regents
so there's a question uh if you have a
projectile
this is basic physics um what
shape best represents that
path okay and so you have like
parabola you know a circle ellipse
whatever
okay and the answer they're looking for
is parabola right right if you do the
math
it's a prayer however however
if it's not actually a parabola it's
close to a parabola
but if you removed earth or scrunched
earth
down to only its center right that path
would continue and orbit the earth and
come back into that segment
so in fact it's a segment of an ellipse
right
more than it's a segment of a parabola
but it's taught
parabola because a parabola equation is
way
easier to calculate with than an ellipse
so
it's so again just because you wrote the
question
and you're testing other people's
knowledge doesn't mean you know enough
knowledge to test people who know more
than you do
that's all i'm saying all right hey
listen that's good well now
we're going to test your knowledge
because we got a bunch of questions that
have been written bring it on okay the
video daily double
chuck what what's behind yes exactly
the universe for 1000 go hey star talk
hey neil
uh thanks for thanks for the chance to
ask some questions
uh so i'm an artist i make pottery some
of it
inspired by the cosmos um and most of
the pots
have a spiral in them somewhere because
i just
i think they look really cool so my
question is very simple
why are there so many spirals in nature
um
interesting oh cool and not just the
universe
in nature period oh yeah yeah
that's this this is joel right okay so i
recognize him he can't
i don't know who this guy is okay
because i
i got right here one of his creations
okay
this is a moon coffee mug right what do
you think of that
and the problem every time i tend it i
taste a bit of basalt
why is this why is this coffee so gritty
[Laughter]
no no each one is unique and i'm very
impressed with just the artisanry
of it um but yeah he he gave me a set of
these
yeah and uh they're all around my office
the funny thing is that he sent me one
as you can see we got one too okay cool
yes and he told me in the note that he
sent me that he had made
several for you and i uh
realized that he sent me one without a
handle i just look at yours
right okay yours has a handle and
clearly you know
uh a minus man you know chuck is just so
ungrateful
joel i apologize for chuck the man
and joel i apologize for you sending me
a handleless
mug thank you
i didn't even realize i was like well
maybe all of his mugs have no handles
maybe this is the way he met he in fact
mine has a little place where your thumb
goes
right on the top of the handle there's a
little place where the thumb goes
and not only is your not only do you
have a handle but it's ergonomic
and mine is just like well chuck i hope
you don't burn your hands okay
all right so here's here's what's going
on in there i'll do my best
to give an answer to this so um
here's what happens if anything goes
around in circles
okay you get a circle all right fine
if however while you were going around
in circles
you move in any direction perpendicular
to the circle
it's no longer a circle it's a spiral
so the circle gets distorted
to move through time in such a way
that you get a spiral like a spiral
staircase or a spiral anything
right so i was in one of the redwood
forests where we were filming
cosmos and i was nice intrigued
but first in the city new york we don't
have big trees like that so
everything about this forest is
completely alien to me
so i'm i'm examining it like i'm on an
alien planet
because i've never seen anything like
this so so i noticed that the tree bark
on many of the trees has is striated
in this sort of very very sort of
high-pitched spiral
going up the tree and every tree did
this
and they all did it in the same
direction and i thought
what is asymmetric in the physiology can
i use that word as applied to plants
yeah in the physiology of a tree that
there's this spiraling going on
if i don't know about the rest of the
plant but it's certainly happening in
the bark so i'm just intrigued by that
but of course
the tree grows upwards so whatever is
otherwise happening in the tree
if it's if there's any kind of sap
movement or whatever else is going on
and i don't know i have no
expertise in plants i'm just saying
combine something that wants to go in a
circle
and have it move upwards you get a
spiral wow
now now that's a spot that's a
three-dimensional spiral now we have
spiral galaxies which is flat
that's a spiral in a flat shape and
i you get that because
the inner parts of the galaxy finish a
loop
faster than the outer parts of the
galaxy so if you have some
system like stars forming in gas clouds
that'll get stretched
okay and a current understanding of
galaxies
is that there's a way a wave of pressure
inside that galaxy called a density wave
that is
moving through the galaxy through the
gas cloud
and that density wave is being stretched
by the rotation
of the galaxy itself and where that
density wave is hitting the gas
you get the formation of stars so
again you have an action happening
combined with a rotation
and then that rotation is not as a solid
object
and there you have it so um by the way
plenty of stuff is not spiral
we have elliptical galaxies there's no
spiral thing for them at all
you know but if you're going to spin
watch for some spiral action
there you go that makes sense yeah yeah
very cool well thanks joel
and thank you for uh once again the
handless cup
and trying to get the basalt out of
there yeah exactly
thank you for thank you for my gritty
morning coffee for my volcanic that
burns my hand
all right all right cool let's
uh move on to i'm gonna combine two
questions together now
this is rud van der linden uh or rude
there's one or the other say the red or
rude i'm imagining his parents didn't
name him
rude i'm just thinking that could you
know
do you spell that how do you spell the
first name are you d
good good okay
all right sounds like rude to me yeah
and rude by the way it's kind of cool
yeah this is kind of cool rude i'm rude
i'm rude
no you're very polite no i am rude
okay so okay rude what's this question
says this hey guys
sad news about the uh arecibo radio
telescope collapsing on itself
i'm so glad i was able to visit it
before the collapse and before
katrina i was wondering does neil have
any personal stories about the
observatory
and what was according to neil the most
important discovery that was made with
the telescope itself thanks
root now let me follow that up with
christine hale
who says hi dr neal just wondering how
the loss
of the arecibo telescope will affect our
scouring of the heavens for possible
alien communication or life so i figured
i'd just combine the two
one because one is you know what's your
personal connection to it
right plus we don't we don't normally do
current events on in q and a so this is
good we'll get to that
after this break oh see what i did there
we're doing cosmic queries uh this is a
fan appreciation edition i'm the grass
tyson chuck nice with me we'll see in a
couple of minutes
we're back the special cosmic queries
fan appreciation edition
now chuck i don't quite know what's
different between this custom aquarius
and others for us to call this fan
appreciation
well everybody's from patreon so
everyone's a patreon oh okay for sure
and we there even some video questions
were taken in so that's how that works
so you left off to give me the two names
of those about
vander linden and charlene hale and rude
wants to know your personal
stories or connections to the arecibo uh
radio telescope uh
because of course it collapsed recently
and uh and
and charlene uh would like to know will
it have an effect
on how we scour the heavens uh for
possible alien communication
or life yeah so the arecibo telescope
was the
largest telescope in the world for
decades
right ever since it was built until back
in the 50s or 60s
uh no no when was it built i think 1960s
until
uh just a few years ago it was the
largest telescope
in the world and in telescopes in
astronomy in general
bigger equals better because if you're
trying to collect rain
outside that's coming down imagine the
rain or just photons photons
okay and you want to collect it you can
use a thimble you can use a bucket
you can use a cauldron or a swimming
pool or a swimming pool you use the
swimming pool you get the most amount of
uh raindrops so it's that simple it's
not more complicated than that
so bigger equals better so
as a since it's a radio telescope it
listens it it observes radio waves
and pulsars gives off radio rapidly
rotating
neutron stars gives off radio waves it
can also detect
things happening in our ionosphere right
this is a part in the upper atmosphere
that's electrically charged
right and old-timers will know
that you could get am radio
from very distant cities late at night
and the reason why you could do that is
am radio waves
once they were broadcast by the antenna
would reflect
off the bottom of their ionosphere and
be able to cover more than the curvature
of the earth
that you could see from your where your
your radio was
whereas fm goes straight out into space
so if you want fm across multiple cities
you need repeaters and all sorts of
other
that you need all manner of of ways to
get that signal into other places
now of course it's everything's cable
driven and satellite driven i'm just
talking about in the day
right so it could observe phenomenon
going on in the ionosphere
in fact the funding originally for
arecibo
was enabled by the us military
to detect the signature of decoy
intercontinental ballistic missiles as
they re-entered the atmosphere
through the on the ionosphere as
launched by russia
what this is how okay so don't let me
that's sensitive listen this is don't
get me started
on well you can but not in this moment
on the two-way street
between astrophysics my field and my
people
and the military oh man we got to do an
explainer on that
we are all my people we're all generally
sort of liberal
anti-war this sort of thing but at the
end of the day
the stuff that we care about the
military cares about stuff the military
cares about
we care about so we have strongly
overlapping venn diagrams
in what we do and what we invent and
what we innovate
so anyhow so the money for that
telescope was driven by
the us military and we knew all along we
could piggyback that fact
and make all manner of other discoveries
so
it also gets us it does radio echo
echoing
so what the telescope could also do
better than any other telescope
was send a signal back out to space
okay because you think of telescopes as
just receiving right but
what you can do is take a signal send it
from where the location of the receiver
bounce it back off the telescope
and send it somewhere in space that you
designate okay
so there are asteroids which are too
small
to really carefully track using optical
regular telescopes so what you can do is
to take a radio signal send it out
beam it back out to space to an
asteroid and that then the reflected
signal comes back to you
you time it you get the distance to that
asteroid and when you get the distance
and you know which way it's going you
get its orbit
and you need you you want to know
what those orbits are for asteroids that
cross earth's orbit
because they will eventually basically
100
hit earth so it's like an echo locator
you not not with sound of course but
still
but but with with radio waves uh
bouncing off and coming back
and so this is uh so it's a highly
useful
telescope in that regard now all right
several years ago okay um
china says we're going to have the
biggest telescope in the world and so
they went up and built a bigger
telescope
twice the collecting area of the
our sibo telescope twice twice twice
around twice i forgot the exact math but
it's about twice
and
so so they too found a natural crater in
the earth as
we found for the arecibo telescope and
built
the largest radio dish in the world
and has an acronym it's called fast the
500 meter
aperture um spherical telescope so its
shape is a spherical
it's right it's it's the geometry of it
good for them
oh so i visited that we we shot some
scenes there for cosmos
for a whole episode the other grass
tyson communists
are the communists wow that's so cool so
you got to see it okay yes i was there
so it's a mile in circumference wow all
right if you walked around the upright
anyhow here's my point the question was
do i have any relation yes i do
my mother my mother
uh while she's born in new york city her
parents are from puerto rico
and in fact her grandparents are from
aracebo
puerto rico oh cool so we have genetic
connection
back to the town that's the nearest town
to that telescope
on the island of puerto rico and so
that's first connection
second we would go visit relatives you
know every christmas and
you know christmas in puerto rico that's
a whole thing yeah that's a whole
by the way at midnight you're there
usually through new year's
at midnight there's a tradition you eat
grapes one per
12 grapes one per um a tone of the clock
right okay and one year they got grapes
but the grapes had seeds in them
you know and i was like eight or
something is like what do i do with the
c don't eat another great quick
you gotta do one third one bird stroke
for a chime anyhow so my point is
um the oh so the telescope
will be missed in that regard but it was
falling out of
disrepair we've known this for about a
decade the the national science funding
foundation started withdrawing money for
support for it so that
means your maintenance doesn't work out
no one writes the article
about the drop in those funds they wait
until the damn
detector falls out of the sky and then
they talk about it as a tragedy
it was a tragedy that had tap roots that
goes back
a decade wow so for me
this plight of the irisebo telescope is
metaphor
for science in america
excellent first the funding drops it
goes out of this repair
and then a few things break putting the
rest of the structure
at stress points because an engineering
design system
if you start taking out support struts
then the rest of it
can't it's designed to be complete if
you start yanking out pieces of it
because it broke
and you don't repair it then that's the
beginning of the end
yeah which in fact it was the beginning
of the end and now the
the the detector falls down out of the
sky
and it's the end of an era and so now if
aliens going to talk to humans
by sending radio signals um they're
going to be speaking
chinese the chinese will be the first
to have that conversation with aliens
now so i'm as an american
i i'm i'm upset that we can't lead that
effort but as a scientist i know
that if you if your country becomes
short-sighted in terms of their
investments
the science can and will still get done
it happened with the super conducting
super collider that we were going to
build
in texas funding began then it all
got cut to zero but europe said we'll
build one
so europe build at the the european
center for nuclear research
cern um they have this the the large
hadron collider and they just
they discovered the higgs boson the god
particle they discovered new frontiers
in particle physics at cern and we
didn't
okay science doesn't care what your
nationality is
all that matters is who it who who is
offering you enlightened
leadership and enlightened governance if
you want to be on that frontier
otherwise you will dance to the tune
played by others
who have made those investments in the
future of this civilization
wow man that was good
well sorry that's a long answer to that
no it's a long answer but i got to tell
you the um
the message at the end of that answer
you can't
it's all worth it where's the price of
admission i'm just saying
okay all right all right i think i'll
give you some more let's do another
video from joel jericho joel has two
videos okay this is this is surprise he
has more than two videos
joel jericho and so yeah he's a jericho
pottery
yeah joel's a big supporter on patreon
yeah yeah and and so
by the way while i was drinking my
coffee an alien climbed out of
the moon mug joel can you lose the
aliens
all right when you get okay go on
all right go ahead let's uh let's let's
hear from joel
another question for you so science and
technology
are replacing a lot of the things that
we used to make with our hands
um they're being made by machines so my
question is
could a machine ever make art
wonder why he asked that that's a scared
artist right there
yeah and your next chuck kennedy
machine tells you really tell jokes
no i i had a conversation with one of
those rolling robots once
you know at a party yeah and and they
sounded really smart so i said
you you sound really smart like where'd
you go to school he said oh solid state
university
that was good that's not bad that's
that's not it's not a bad joke kill that
robot
[Laughter]
so i think machines so for me
let me offer my definition of art art is
reality through the lens of someone with
imagination
which upon being shared with you allow
you to see
the world not only with fresh eyes
but with a perspective that
can enhance the beauty of your life
and the life of others okay that's what
i think of
by the way art capital a sculptures
screenwriters
set designers yeah all of art so
can a computer do art i think computers
as if they're programmed by you
to just do something that's already
known to do
no it's not going to do art or it'll
duplicate somebody else's art
right that's not art that's just forgery
right
so so art for me has got to come from a
creative place
that no good art has to come from a
creative place
that is not yet been tapped
by anyone else if you're going to
advance
the world of art right so so for a
computer to do that
it has to be full up genuine artificial
intelligence
yeah it would have to be basically human
yeah they have to be exactly the exact
way it have to be uh it'd have to have
the exact same
i would say neurological capabilities
that we do but it wouldn't have to be
the same
it would just have to be have the
capacity to have a thought
that was never had before right yeah
exactly
whether or not it's the same thought we
had right it would just have to be
an original thought an original thought
right that's right because i mean think
about it so you look at like just take
monet for
or any of the impressionists right i
don't know who the first impressionist
was
but he was probably nearsighted
someone go back through time and say
can't put one of these on
he's like oh wait a minute so that's how
this stuff really
wait a minute so oh that's how stuff
really looks
so it but it was either that he was
nearsighted
or he was like why can't
why wouldn't i see why couldn't i see
the world
in this gauzy like perspective
what surely contributed to that was the
arrival of photography
absolutely these are coincident in time
right because photography is not now i
can capture reality
basically exactly as reality it is i
don't need you to paint a portrait of me
to capture the reality of me absolutely
now if you're going to paint a portrait
okay give me three eyeballs on one side
or whatever
do something different and imaginative
because if i want
exactly me i'll just take a photo yeah
there we go so yeah
yeah oh wow that's really cool right so
yeah i think that's the kind of computer
you need
and the day that happens you know we'll
just become their pets
because we're all screwed when that
happens
it's a wrap it's a wrap on us all okay
okay do you know how we created you know
how we domesticated
uh the cats and dogs i know by killing
the ones that bit us
oh god okay so you have a litter
all right and some are really nice and
cuddly and you pet them and they purr
and they do that or whatever
and then another one's like scratching
and hugging at you dead no that one
kill that one that and so you're
selectively
editing the gene pool of these creatures
for their temperament
and so now you went from a wolf to
uh a a a poodle right or a
or what's that the pomeranian you know
or a yorkie
with a lap dog right so um the point is
if the the day ai becomes our overlord
um it would you just want to be nice to
them so you can become their pets
otherwise don't be the human who kicks
and fights
[Laughter]
don't be that human your ass is gone
because you will not outsmart the ai
yeah because they're designed to be
somewhat as smart or smarter than
anything we
ever will be in the same way we design
we program computers to be better at us
at chess right okay computer beat
kasparov for goodness sake right
a computer beat the best jeopardy
champion so we're already kind of
no there's certain things they're better
at us that but if they start running
things
okay yeah just learn how to purr
all right we got to take another quick
break and when we come back more
uh cosmic query's uh fan appreciation
edition
when star talk returns
we're back star talk cosmo aquarius fan
appreciation edition
shuck spending all this time just
blathering you know
let's go get some more questions okay i
gotta stop this i gotta
i gotta no i know you always say it but
it's it's good
no no no no okay it's i mean
if you went to the bank right and
you said i'd like to withdraw a hundred
dollars and the bank manager comes out
and says
oh hi dr tyson by the way today
is dr tyson appreciation day now in
addition to your hundred dollars
here are and he counted out by ones
another hundred dollars
okay would you say bro what are you
doing
i'm in a hurry okay i gotta get out of
here i gotta go
all right no you let them count out the
hundred dollars at once and then you
take it and you say thank you very much
and that hundred was not out of your
account it was
so the bank bank decision in your favor
okay monopoly card all right it's all
gravy well thank you for the bank
analogy
yeah there you go let's go to uh tracy
scrubber
who says uh dr tyson what do you
consider
to be the most persistent belief in
physics
or astronomy which has already been
disproven
but that is still perpetuated in popular
culture
and or schools oh
wow what a great question okay that's
like a multi-part thing going on there
okay yeah so
um the concept of belief i i
prefer to use that word for when you
think something is true in the absence
of evidence
so um belief doesn't have much
currency in the sciences what happens is
i have
some marginal evidence that something
might be true
so i can say i believe it's true but
that's not
i have this much evidence to say it's
true what does your evidence say
my evidence says is the opposite of that
so the third person comes and say
no what i found is there's a hybrid of
those two things that you're saying
and this is the real truth then a fourth
person says i agree with that third
person and the fifth person says i agree
with that third person
and you assemble information and data
and observations so that there's an
emergent objective truth
right so it's not like we're also let's
just believe this is true and get on
with life
no that's not quite the the mechanism
of what's going on here so what you
really want to know is there anything
that we long thought
would be true turn out to not be true
but the public still believes
um i
no the public belief stuff that we
always knew was never true
so no spaceships don't make sound in
space
okay so so star wars would be silent
movie
all right so uh that's one that we
always knew was not true and the public
doesn't
seem to get it um we knew the world was
round
uh in ancient greece forget this
columbus stuff where
people thought no the educated people
knew earth was round
um ancient greece they knew earth was
around you know they knew earth was
around
because lunar eclipses okay where
earth's shadow is cast
onto the full moon always made
a curved shadow okay and
the shadow was a circular shadow and the
only shape object
that will always make a circular shadow
there's a sphere no matter what angle
the light comes from that's right so the
ancient greeks were clever people
and they recognized this and they saw
that it would be at different angles and
they always got that
that that that that a circular shadow on
the thing
the only way you can get a circle is if
we are a sphere so so it's been known
for a thousand years yet
there are emerging people today who are
certain earth is flat
so i i so no there's nothing that we
have carried with us that is yet to be
confirmed
or has been confirmed in in the negative
that the public
still believes not in physics you get
some of that in medicine
okay always oh oh my gosh
oh this is chicken soup this is period
right in
six days right okay ginkgo biloba
okay so something you know my favorite
is the chicken soup one so
the way it goes is uh there's no better
cure than grandma's chicken soup
okay and with uh that and other good
traditional cures
will make you better in a week right but
but without them
your cold will linger for seven days
yeah
so if you look at sort of uh the
what they used to call old um um wives
tales they used to call it that
i don't know how it even got that term
but just things that
lore handed down another one is if i if
i roll you in front of the window and
the window's open and it's cold air
you'll catch pneumonia
right okay i heard that from my
grandmother and i'm thinking why would
you catch them is there like pneumonia
sitting outside the window ready to come
in only when it's cold outside
like what it what and i never believed
it but i heard it
okay i watch movies you know go to tcm
movies black and white movies from the
1940s and 50s
it is all throughout the movies okay
there's a hitchcock movie where
somebody's trying to kill somebody who's
wheelchair-bound
and rolls him in front of a window opens
the window in the winter and then leaves
them there and they catch the death of
cold and die
this is but today you don't have you
don't see that in storytelling
so that must have gotten through right
yeah
it must have okay gotten through that no
that's no longer the case
i was told by my grandmother wear your
slippers otherwise you'll catch a death
of cold
at night and how am i gonna catch a cold
through the bottom of my feet
you know i you know i have calluses
if a coal gets through the calluses in
the bottom of my feet give it to him
exactly yeah all right so i think in
other profession
physics not so much got you okay that's
cool
keep it going all right let's keep it
going this is timothy l johnson timothy
says
chuck you can pronounce my name i
promise
timothy johnson thank you thank you ty
mafi
joe hanson uh then he says dr tyson
i wanted to pick your brain in your
opinion what is the most
fascinating thing that we have
discovered
in our known universe and how many ways
could it kill you
[Laughter]
i think nothing beats black holes there
you go
and a black hole kill you a hundred
different ways there you go okay
so uh the first discovered black hole
was
um it was an a source of
x-rays and ultraviolet light in
the constellation scorpius no it might
have been cygnus no the first one was in
cygnus
the constellation cygnus and you have a
uh when you have a black hole and
material getting filleted off of a star
in orbit around it that mature falling
in
radiates copiously before it
enters the abyss and so we knew that you
calculated this is the signature a black
hole would give us
as matter falls in and so you look for
those in the sky so now the catalog we
have no end
of catalogued black holes so it's
definitely black holes and they've
captured our imagination in movies in
storytelling
disney had a movie the black hole back
in the 70s i think they're re
redoing it um so yeah it's got to be
black holes and my favorite way to die
is falling into a black hole
i don't get hit by a bus i don't want to
die and i think
put me throw me into a black hole good
for you
mine is sleep
why not be part of an experiment while
you're doing this
because i don't want to be there at all
because i'm dying
i'm told i haven't heard this verified
that during the french revolution we're
cutting off everybody's heads
right if you know you're going to die
that way why not participate in some
science experiments right so for example
your eyes
connect directly to your brain and they
don't need the rest of your body right
okay
you can stop your heart briefly and
you're still kind of alive while that's
happening so cut off your head
go to the rolling head right before it
completely dies
and ask because your ears are still
connected
yeah how many fingers do you see why
don't you blink
so i'm told i didn't verified that there
was still
some brief brain activity right now
there's an experiment
okay okay why waste a guillotined head
when you could
so if i if i gotta die throw me a black
hole i'll give you all the data you want
there you go all right oh god i'm gonna
get a t-shirt
science why waste a guillotine head
[Laughter]
we gotta get it oh that's so great oh by
the way i mean in all seriousness there
was
um the there was a prisoner who
voluntarily donated his body
to be micro-sliced
okay do you know how you do this okay so
the oh no this is a prisoner who was on
death row
okay voluntarily did they said yes give
my body to medicine
so they do that then you like mostly
freeze the body
and then you just start taking slices
all right so ideally you'd have three
bodies to do this with one you'd slice
this way
right when you slice this way top to
bottom
left to right and then front to back
then you'd have thin
transparent slices of the human body
that you could compare
to mri images of the three-dimensional
cross-section of the body
nice so i i own a book that is this
sliced
uh prisoner who was on death row and if
you're a cannibal it makes for a lovely
carpage
slice human that's great or you're fried
you get
human chips cutting potatoes thin
all right but i hope kids aren't
listening to this show are we pg-13 i
think we're pj
listen we're talking nutrition that's
all uh
says hey neil hey chuck my question is
about the elasticity of
these of of expansion of space
base is expanding in all directions and
everything is moving away from
everything else
why isn't the space within our own solar
system
expanding why doesn't the expansion of
space
destabilize orbits why doesn't
the expansion stretch the space
currently occupied
by the earth and in turn stretch
us this person's clearly lost some sleep
if you've got ten questions that just
just
vomit out out of one idea his question
was like a little russian nesting doll
yes that's right so excellent question
so here's what's going on
the stretching of the fabric of space
and time from the expansion of the
universe
okay um is
at all times competing against gravity
that would prevent it
okay on the largest scale
it is winning on the smallest scales
it's not
the sun has a good grip on the planets
and the
urge for space to stretch within the
confines of the solar system
is not higher than the success of the
sun keeping everybody in orbit
however in the
dark energy future scenario of the
universe
where the universe will continue to
expand and accelerate
in its expansion the expansion will
become
more and more significant in places
where it
didn't previously have a stronghold
and yes eventually that extreme future
universe
where you have exponential expansion
will start ripping apart
solar systems yes the sun will no longer
be able to hold on to it
against the stretching of space between
the sun
and the earth and the rest of the
planets then it'll start
now the electromagnetic forces are
stronger than gravitational forces so
what's holding earth together
is stronger than the sun's gravity on
the earth so the earth will struggle and
hold on
until it will break apart and this will
continue
until there's some of us worried
about the big rip and
this will take place when it tries to
stretch the very quantum realm
that is the tiniest representation of
the fabric
of space and time there is because that
we don't think is stretchable at all and
if you get into that realm you have
overcome
even the quantum realm and we think
space will just rip
and we don't know what that'll look like
and it's kind of scary
and in fact star talk has another book
coming out do you know this in the
spring
yeah okay spring 2021 it's
you know what that book is called
it's called i shouldn't be announcing
yet because i don't think it's on
shelves yet because
they're still in production so don't
don't look for it yet okay but it's
called cosmic queries
nice and in there is the whole
discussion
about the expansion of the universe and
how it could in one scenario
could end up in the big rip in which
case all of the nesting doll scenarios
described by um what's the person's name
again
uh nissan uh will will be realized
and that'll be the end of the universe
as we know it there you go
have a nice day yes have a great day a
big rip he who smelt it dealt it there
you go
so we got time for one more question
chuck well that means we got to go to
our last video question from joel
jericho joe gets three questions yes sir
he does
dude he must be giving us a lot of money
oh my god yes sir he is
okay
okay all right no we're not that crass
but we just we
like to joke about it but no we're very
loving okay what so
what does it get here it is so there are
some scientists in history who
were also interested in art as part of
their process
like albert einstein had his violin
right next to his
desk where he would do his math problems
and when he'd get stuck on a math
problem
he would take a break and play the
violin um
so as a scientist are there any
parts of your process that involve doing
anything
artistic anything non that's that's not
just doing science
um that helps you with your own
scientific problems or ideas
excellent questions so let me
uh well this i don't know if we have
time for me to give the full answer
that that question deserves let me let
me
go quick and briefly so the art science
relationship
is not an equal two-way street okay
there are discoveries in science
that directly impact how the artist
does art true okay from some from the
uh everything to everything well yeah
yeah so computer visualization in movies
is all the science and engineering that
went into the computer that the visual
the visualizers are using all of whom
are artists to
to do their craft the the all the stuff
that's happening on tablets now all of
the
when when neon was discovered or
invented as a means of lighting
in colors artists picked up on it
immediately and started doing sculptures
with neon bulbs right and so
so the progress of science and
engineering directly affects art
the question is does art directly affect
science i think the actual answer to
that is no
there is no scientific discovery where
the person says
this is where a g chord on my
guitar came in there's no that's not
there is no
such infusion that being said
the value of art to the scientist i
don't think is any different from the
value of art
to anybody who knows the value of art
it is a place for you to stimulate
parts of your brain that are wired
differently from all the other ways your
brain is wired
right and that could possibly stimulate
new synaptic possibilities
in what your next thought will be my
entire phd thesis
was written to the music
of the nine symphonies of beethoven and
all of the string quartets
okay so i i me and ludwig
go way back on this okay so
so in that case i'm not writing and then
looking at art
i'm writing and listening to uh artistic
creativity
in the regime of classical music so
science has a direct
impact whereas art may have
a direct inspiration uh inspirational
impact
correct it's not as though einstein
played the violin and said oh there's a
note i'm going to put that note in there
that's not really what that is i see
einstein and the violin
not so much as an escape from his work
not
so much as something that will directly
plug into his work
but as a respite right from his work
and if you have a brief respite it lets
the brain
breathe breathe i like that yeah
metaphorically breathe
so that new source or maybe literally
breathe new oxygen comes in
to feed new thoughts so i've always been
a fan of art
my brother is an artist um and
uh so my whole life and he went to the
high school of music and art uh
just as a we both native new yorkers i
went to the
bronx high school of science so we both
sort of were fed by
these institutions in new york that knew
and understand such people
walk around who could benefit from this
kind of stimulation
so so yes i i gotta go with joel
that it can help inspire you
not directly it takes it
shows your brain a different palette
on which to think before you return to
what you were doing before
cool yeah i like that answer i don't
know okay well i'm glad yeah
thank you joel for your three daily
doubles and your money
your chuck stop being so crass
and maybe he'll get the basalt out of
this now some people don't know what
basalt is basalt is just like
hardened lava lava fields right and so
the darkened areas of the moon
are basalt we went over that in one of
the um explainer videos explainers we
talked about making craters
but anyway this definitely evokes um the
the the universe and moons without
actually being a representation of a
moon and that's why i like art to be
don't be the moon be something that the
moon evokes
that makes you feel the moon nice
i just want to handle no you're just
trying to get it
okay and like i've said in the van
gogh's starry night
that's clearly not what he saw but it's
definitely what he felt
while he was watching that night sky
and i want to i want a piece of what
artists feel
because i want to feel and see the way
they do nice
i myself am not the artist so i need
their help
we got to wrap it up there chuck always
a pleasure
always good to have you man okay this
has been star talk
cosmic queries fan appreciation edition
and as always i bid you for the whole
star talk family
to keep looking up
you